hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm back here with waiting the same
basement that I was when the last video
came out and this time we're gonna be
playing diving by the way say hi wait hi
guys so we're gonna be doing I know what
we're gonna be doing I've got been
excited for this yeah it's gonna be
playing dive kick and as an added bonus
whoever loses has to take a drink of hot
sauce the penis is what he has his
fridge and I wanted to do it so badly
he's so back why could we do the maple
syrup
uh-huh so dad kick do you know what that
kick is about Oh set it up diamond kick
we tried it just a little bit and he
didn't do so good no no he did not know
so good so we're gonna play it and he is
a very bad player of games in general in
this favor game he's pretty bit oh it's
on now so either way we're gonna either
play until one round proceed and then
we're gonna pick our character who's
gonna it's gonna be boring oh yeah oh
there we go final and jump ready ready
ready I didn't want it to be totally
unfair so I taught him how to play but
not that much
I kind of ran out of there the webcam is
actually shut not over there over here
Iori still our rights monitor setup
aren't you you usually do that don't you
oh you're gonna you're the pink guy
there's rope hey yeah I'm mixing it up
oh okay
love yourself and the world will follow
soon yeah wait I thought I was an uncle
sin site oh that's uncle sensei the
other characters I was playing for oh
God oh one row nice one dudes dudes
welcome back I can double
your fancy moves can stop me now oh god
it smells looting the money just be good
it's got to get really close to each
other well that's one point to me you
gonna be a tasty glass of hot sauce for
you oh no you do when you get it we're
gonna did what are you doing plead under
twelve ahead I'm ready Gangnam style of
here and you're the only lawyer you know
are you gonna do something here oh we
ran out I don't because you get the
stupid win from winning it there leave
me ammo man you know you like a friggin
missile on me here you've got that you
stop that right now
try just try it again try it you don't
know what are you gonna do now Frank no
you're gonna no no no maybe you should
stop it shouldn't douchebag oh god I
keep jumping backwards when I want to
die
no no no you want make it better every
300 Jesus yeah
oh that's a short game we could do it
again
rematch yay oh maybe we should select
different characters what are you guys
on you can't use now you they want new
characters Derby my oh we're badger I
think I'm not really sure I'm aware we
look like oh we're bad you alright
anyway we got new characters and now
we're gonna do best two out of three so
if I win this one yeah I'm fine you got
so much I don't know how I'm just you
good oh I'm a werewolf myself under you
it didn't feel it oh oh god his own dumb
I do a quick quick quick quick quick
yeah
Wow Wow oh hello Ando we're blowing up
this money no no we're good actually we
got it on a level that's actually not so
bad
oh you got big Oh who's in the
background over there uh scared girl
yeah come on man you don't know
ah oh yeah happening yeah lying there we
really are time yes kha'zix can't be the
class I don't have any special moves
like you yeah you're bounced out of the
frigging arena Rick one little a chick
we're going to did you give it to
why do you get the special ability do
that kill their bold button glowing what
am i doing I don't know go boy let me do
stop it it's um Oh
what's your star for knowing Oh evil
character see the quiz bowl you saw fast
I was going in the world that you're
able to kill me I don't know there's
yeah that's weird why do we mention that
we have no idea how to play this game
other than divekick I didn't know there
was actually strategy to the game
no no gig on your club you're still
writing I'm dedicated to my job are you
gonna say that would be the death of you
you've not very good with change how how
do you do Oh
headshot now you're gonna be all
disoriented didn't you never know we're
gonna be going Oh
Oh who's the winner now I'll never go
comes down to this little day no no I
get ready to do it three in a row
oh all right
oh my god lose get one point you need to
come to me I don't even need to go to
you I don't know they just I don't know
what I'm doing Wow yes it was a point of
whatever I did cool goes Marco boy are
you gonna be so stupid
that's stupid what do these and call me
in the morning
I was waiting back you hit like for the
Tippmann so stupid your ass my your ass
all you all do they got the overpowered
characters every single time you're able
to kill me over mean we will work as you
saw I was sipping around a million miles
now you did your lightning whip and
killed me whoa I don't know about this I
couldn't control where I was going
nothing you ain't just holding me the
whole damn mistake - but you did y'all
have the same buns and hello and
complain just kept fresh soup damage
alright well the bet was that one of us
would drink a drink of this oh well we
didn't mention is that the winner would
be pouring how much I would drink or we
would drink how much I'm gonna drink
Oh God I'd like a bite me in the butt
wonder oh not much you guys think I
should put the whole bottle up to this
pool how much would you like Christopher
oh you know healthy serving something to
keep my bowl Oh God not drinkable that's
nothing you drink thankfully this isn't
spicier than that come on I gotta give a
hearty helping else that look like more
oh not that Manono yelled out of God
who's overruling a shots worth that's
movie war god are you asked for it Oh
God looking at it now doesn't look as
good as I thought it would
it doesn't look good at all who didn't
expect to be drinking I didn't expect
you to be drinking tonight okay I got
enough drink your water not my friend
ah it's like Brigid dude babe what are
you revealing it another I'm gonna join
you
you're gonna join me join your oh god
it's like greedy Jews made it something
go down you feel like Porsche with your
tongue to the bag you're through having
so bad haha it's not haughty there's
medium sauce a little kick to a bit but
that hits the back of your do is not but
that bad ignore my rhymes all day look
they're not there uh hahaha
Oh God why do we do these ah why do we
do these things fun time that one things
the taste you're right just like this
thing you choose baby she's gonna shove
it back my eyes are sad they're like my
dogs
go either way um that was divekick with
a special kicker in the pants bonus so
thank you all so much for what they once
again wait for joining me for this wild
experiment we're all still recording
right we are we are leaving we were done
kill somebody who's anything so thank
you again everybody for watching
remember to click in the description
below or on a him fun Q there's fur this
whatever his channel Lord out have them
leave you enjoyed this leave a like down
below for our suffering sake well this
shows I'm left you want me to down that
thank you guys thanks guessing and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye guys oh that's awful Oh behalf if
eligos gonna puke this time just sitting
there I couldn't get it to go down